what up its 2018 [ __ ] hey hey waffle
whoa she's a be like what else comes
after that hello everyone welcome to
2018 we are going to be kickin the new
year off right making some delicious
grain free gluten free waffles two ways
so I am kind of obsessed my waffle iron
not gonna lie
I already made a delicious birthday cake
waffle just this past December to
celebrate my big three-o and today I
thought I'd share with you two of my
favorite potato base waffles so what
we're gonna be doing is a sweet and a
savory we're gonna do my loaded baked
potato waffle and we're gonna be doing
my sweet potato latke waffle with an
apple and cranberry compote sounds
really yummy because it is really yummy
and I am super excited to get into it
let's do this
first up my loaded potato waffle
first I create my waffle mix by mixing
together some grated white potato and
some shredded cheddar cheese some beaten
eggs salt and some pepper give it a good
stir to incorporate all those goodies
and then pre-heat your waffle iron now
it's time to cook I add a generous
amount of the waffle mixture to my
waffle iron and spread it out so it's
nice and even closer up and let it cook
until golden brown next i fry an egg and
a little bit of oil in a non-stick
skillet just until the whites are cooked
through
now it's time to load up that potato I
start by adding a gulp of sour cream
some crispy bacon bits my fried egg and
some pretty chives get in there next up
my sweet potato waffles with apple
cranberry compote
I start by making my compote into a
sauce pot I add some fresh cranberries
some diced apples apple cider and some
minced of dates pop a lid on and bring
to a simmer until the cranberries burst
and everything gets nice and syrupy and
thick now I make my waffle mix by mixing
together some shredded sweet potatoes
some potato flour some olive oil some
ginger cinnamon and nutmeg as well as
some eggs and a pinch of salt give
everything a good stir until it's nicely
incorporated and then pre-heat your
waffle iron now let's get cooking to my
waffle iron I add a nice healthy amount
of my mixture closer up and let it cook
until it's golden brown now it's time to
garnish i layer my waffles with our
beautiful apple cranberry compote a
sprinkling of crushed pecans and of
course lots of luscious maple syrup
[Music]
dig in well guys I hope you got a waffle
iron for Christmas because you're gonna
be wanting to make these recipes ASAP
right I think so so if you love this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below some of your
favorite waffle topping inspirations
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time in Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]
[Music]